Ну я хочу в доме Ну я хочу в домі своєму
жити чесне слово ми його будували щоб
Старість зустріти у мене було все до
дрібниць
199 Я розумію що це є відновленням цих
коштів на все Не хватає бо руйнування
дуже великий зараз все дуже дороге вже в
кінці ну
закінчилась Кошти я просто ну і сили
Кошти я просто так без надії відправив
запрос думаю хоч може щось компенсує
А ти держава Я вже ні на що більше не
розраховую усі ці українці мають
пошкоджене або повністю знищена
російськими військами житло чи можна
його відбудувати за підтримки
держпрограми є відновлення чи справді
Вона працює кому і за яких умов дадуть
гроші
[музика]
пані Лариса досі не може повірити що чує
ці звуки від будови у себе в оселі понад
рік Вона разом з родиною мешкала серед
руїн які по собі лишили російські
окупанти в Ірпені в березні 2022 року
мої діти стояли на вулиці коли летів
снаряд і вони буквально я до 30 не
дорахувала коли вони забігли в хату і
закрили двері і снаряд влетів в ванну
будинок був пошкоджений вікна всі
пошкоджені були дах весь пошкоджений все
тепло в хату В мене просто було таке
звідки я візьму фінанси щоб відновити
свій будинок
персик побитий яблуня побита але бачите
все рівно її яблука всерівно є життя цей
сад єдине що родині жінки вдалося
відновити тут самотужки на інше коштів
не було заміна фасаду і покрівлі нині
відбувається за рахунок держави у травні
пані Лариса онлайн подала заявку на
програму її відновлення за якою їй
пообіцяли компенсацію до 200 тисяч
гривень і тут дзвонять і кажуть так в
мене є пільга Так у мене є пільга в мене
цукровий діабет Я з інвалідністю в мене
син
з інвалідністю але що так швидко це буде
і зразу на другий день була комісія Вони
все зафіксували все заміряли все зробили
і буквально три тижні і ми отримали це
199 Я розумію що це є відновлення та
коли Справа дійшла до використання
коштів жінка змогла придбати виключно
певний перелік товарів у обмеженій кіль
Кості магазинів передбачених програмою
втім отриманих 199 тисяч від держави і
так не вистачило на заміну вікон дверей
та частково ще одного фасаду на цих
коштів на все Не хватає бо руйнування
дуже великий зараз все дуже дороге
на якому етапі у нас робота що ми
сьогодні зробили так
стіни гіпсокартону
будівельники тут теж найняті за кошти з
є відновлення що є додатковий можливість
у програми не на камеру жінка каже
приходять нерегулярно і через це роботи
вже затягнулися на два тижні
однак пані Ларису тішить що робота таки
зрушила з місця у неї Та в сусідів що
також отримали державні компенсації
загалом відшкодування до 200 тисяч
гривень вже отримали трохи більше 5
тисяч українців серед них жодної людини
у цій сусідній громаді тут у селі
Горенка на компенсацію від держави ще у
травні подали понад 700 заявок з них
опрацьовано менше третини люди до кінця
не розуміють процедури і не подають всі
ті документи які вимагаються постановою
Кабінету Міністрів тобто
не надають або право власності або права
власності на земельну ділянку фото
відеофіксація Тобто Це трошки затягує
процес пані Лариса місцева жителька і
членкиня комісії є відновлення яка
оглядає будинки після отримання Запитів
разом ще з кількома членами громади вона
ухвалює рішення Яку суму відшкодування
Має отримати окрема родина
у дворі пана Анатолія вже не видно усіх
ушкоджень від уламків російських
снарядів вікна та двері чоловік замінив
за власні кошти вже в кінці ну
закінчилась Кошти я просто ну і сили
Кошти я просто так без надії відправив
запрос думаю хоч може щось
компенсує
А ти держава подав в заяву я в дію
11.05.23 вже неділі дві назад до це
прийшли сповіщення вони є відновлення
побитий фасад підраховує комісія
теоретично вдасться відновити за кошти і
відновлення 147 тисяч гривень це все
потрібно знімати далі он я бачу підшивка
буває так що порахують наприклад там
заміну покрівлі металочерепиці чи
шиферу до 100 тисяч гривень коли
починають знімати А там потрібно міняти
стропильну систему повністю або частково
Тобто це все
ну це складно вирахувати кошторис для
нарахування виплат комісія створює на
основі готових шаблонів яких написано
скільки в середньому грошей потрібно на
той чи інший вид ремонту А на сайті
програми вказаний перелік магазинів де
купити матеріали пан Анатолію не
віриться що така відбудова буде
ефективною в його випадку вона сказала
Да ми вам скажемо в яких організаціях
купити цей матеріал і які організації це
будуть робити чому я не можу знайти
матеріал в якомусь іншому місці де він
дешевше де мені якість більше
подобається Хай обирає
чи подобається йому Ця пропозиція чи дні
разом з матеріалами у профільному
міністерстві яке реалізує програму
відшкодувань запевняють такі обмеження
запровадили аби люди витратили гроші
дійсно на відбудову а не на якісь інші
потреби цей Фактор вплинув І на те що
чиновники відмовилися від початкової
ідеї встановити більший ліміт виплат
півмільйона гривень і ще дискутують коли
дати можливість людям отримувати таку
суму
вони
і закладені філософією компонентом
поєднання від 200 до 500 там трохи
складніше будуть моменти по
моніторингових використання тому що сума
як ви розумієте значно більше проблема
використання будь-яких сум відшкодування
кажуть фахівці будівельної галузі це
стабільне здорожчання вартості
будматеріалів у зв'язку з їх дефіцитом
та інфляцією що стосується Великого Бубу
відновлення то його наразі не буде поки
не буде
завершення військових дій в Україні
що стосується поточного
відновлення зруйнованих об'єктів
особливо стосується об'єктів
інфраструктури на це також необхідно
доволі велика кількість будматеріалів
і наразі країна
імпортує такі складові Які в нас в
у нас не хватає таких будматеріалів усе
видно на практиці відбудова частково
пошкодженого житла в багатьох випадках
потребує Суми більшої за закладену
першої хвилі
її від 200 тисяч гривень це констатують
у комісії в горинці розглядаючи свіжі
заявки це от те що подаються ось заміна
дверей заміна вікон частково замінили
частково ще потрібно Ось цією покрівлею
вона не влізе в 200 тисяч тут повністю
Потрібно цю частину перекривати після
огляду комісії у житла це одразу сказали
і Пані олені вона та її родина у 2014
році втратили домівку на Луганщині а
минулоріч російський снаряд майже
повністю знищив нову оселю у мужчині на
Київщині Ну я хочу в домі Ну я хочу в
домі своєму жити чесне слово ми його
будували щоб Старість зустріти у мене
було все до дрібниць
кий не чекаючи допомоги держави кілька
місяців тому родина почала відбудову
дому за власний кошт ось
майстерню мені зробили просто це все моє
приладдя Ось бачите це буде Моя
майстерня дому ще нема дах не покритий а
тут у мене будуть стелажі
усі чеки з ремонту Олена зберігає втім з
шовком думає про вже витрачену суму о-о
Боже ви що скажу не один мільйон гривень
таким Я колена держава теж компенсує
витрати за здійснення самостійну ремонти
проєкти ініціативи вже готують каже
заступниця міністра розвитку громад
території та інфраструктури А гроші на
її думку люди зможуть отримати вже цього
року також для тих хто зовсім не
відбудовував знищені оселі вже з 1
серпня запрацювала програма компенсації
за повністю зруйноване житло це Нова
хвиля її відновлення за якою можна
отримати сертифікати на повну відбудову
або купівлю нового дому чи квартири
рівноцінних за вартістю зруйнованих
квадратних метрів родина самостійно
обирає місце розташування характеристики
квартири будь-що з кінця вересня
поточного року люди зможуть
реалізовувати сертифікати Тобто це
відбудеться у поточному році Крім того
ми в поточному році плануємо впровадити
механізм компенсації за знищене майно на
територіях перед тим як продовжувати
програму каже одна з авторок закону про
компенсації депутатка Олена Шуляк варто
врахувати недоліки першої хвилі зокрема
низьку активність роботи комісії як от у
Києві на Харківщині та на Херсонщині а
також проблеми старшого покоління з
подальшою заявок онлайн і втратою
деякими українцями необхідних документів
люди виїхали не завжди з собою взяли
документи
документи згоріли в тій домівці яка
знищена ну тобто таких випадків досить
багато а законодавством передбачено що
коли немає правостановлюючих документів
необхідно звернутися до суду ми знаємо
що наші суди можуть різні справи
розглядати рік 2-3-5 тому ми зараз з
міністерством юстиції з колегами
народними депутатами розробляємо
внесення зміни до законодавства у
вигляді спрощеного судового порядку саме
для таких людей попри можливість
вдосконалення наразі вже фактично відомо
будь-яким з варіантів компенсації
українці зможуть скористатися лише один
раз і лише за одним з напрямків тобто
відшкодувати їх вже наявні власні
витрати і доробити ремонт за кошти її
відновлення не вийде тоді виділених
державою грошей запевняють у профільному
міністерстві точно вистачить усім Наразі
це майже півмільйона українців які
офіційно зареєстрували пошкоджене чи
знищене житло ті хто не може чекати на
державні кошти продовжують звертатися по
допомогу до волонтерів та благодійних
фондів як це зробив пенсіонер з Ірпеня
пан Микола
Я вже ні на що більше не розраховую це
все-таки люди коли люди не вимагають у
тебе навіть паспорта немає розмови про
гроші
допомагати нас дуже багато таких
будинків і все тримається на волонтерах
періг в тому я сама собі ставила вікна
за свій рахунок на тобто я ж розумію що
це зовсім не ці гроші і це не так легко
їх дістати з держави заявок від
власників пошкодженого аби знищеного
житла настільки багато каже координатор
волонтерів Будівельників що комусь
змушені відмовляти ми працюємо з фондами
благодійними міжнародними локально
українськими також з бізнесом фонди
розглядають заявки і там узгоджують
Якісь вони якісь ні якщо наприклад оцей
будинок узгодили нам надали весь
необхідний матеріал Ми приїхали і робимо
попри труднощі відбудови які чекають і
на таких як Лариса що вже витратила
компенсацію від держави на частковий
ремонт жінка вірить зрештою всі матимуть
оновлене житло втім де самі брати кошти
на решту ремонту поки не знає живемо
живемо далі і віримо в перемогу віримо в
те що воно все зміниться і так не буде
Ну я так вірю Може Ви колись приїдете А
в нас буде тут краса неймовірна
[музика]